The following content is
provided by MIT OpenCourseWare
under a Creative Commons
license.
Additional information about
our license and MIT
OpenCourseWare in general is
available at ocw.mit.edu.
All right.
Let's continue,
then, on this unit of kinetics.
Today, we are going to talk
about temperature,
and we are going to talk about
collisions, and we are going to
talk about activation energies
and activated complexes.
And we are still in Chapter 13
in your book.
When we started this unit on
kinetics, we listed a bunch of
things that can affect a rate of
a reaction.
And let's just review what we
have talked about and what we
have left to talk about.
We talked about mechanisms of
reactions.
One step, two steps,
fast steps, slow steps.
That can affect the rate of the
reaction.
We talked about concentration
of material.
We talked about nature of
material.
We talked about first-order and
second-order integrated rate
laws.
Today, we are going to talk
about temperature,
then Monday we are going to
talk about the use of catalysts,
and then Wednesday,
again, is a review.
We are right at the bottom of
our list here of things
affecting rates of reaction.
The affect of temperature.
If you are in the gas phase,
it is sort of the qualitative
observation that if you increase
the temperature the rate
increases.
You've probably sort of thought
about this, that if you want to
make something go faster,
you add some heat.
Today we are going to talk
about quantitative affects and
how you can actually calculate a
change in rate constant if the
temperature of the reaction is
changed.
Here we go back to 1889.
That is when Arrhenius plotted
rate constants versus
temperature.
And he was looking to get a
straight line.
He found that if he used the
natural log of the rate
constants and plotted that
against inverse temperature,
he got a straight line.
Here is what one of those plots
look like.
The rate constants are varying
exponentially with inverse
temperature.
On one axis,
we have the natural log of the
rate constant k.
On the other axis,
we have one over temperature.
And so this is the equation
that is being plotted.
Again, we have natural log of k
on one axis.
That is rate constant.
The other axis is one over
temperature.
And so if this is one over
temperature on this axis,
then the slope of the line is
minus Ea, activation energy,
over R, which is the gas
constant.
Up here, activation energy E
sub a and R,
our gas constant.
And the intercept of the line,
then, is the natural log of
capital A.
And capital A has several
different names.
You will see it listed in
different books as different
things.
I think our book usually refers
to it as factor A,
or the pre-exponential factor.
And it would have the same
units as k.
If one plots natural log of
rate constants over one
temperature, one could determine
the activation energy for a
reaction or the factor A for a
particular reaction.
These quantities,
factor A and activation energy,
are dependent on the reaction
being studied.
There will be a particular
measured value for one
particular reaction.
Let's think a little bit more
about what these quantities are.
Factor A, is it temperature
dependent?
No, it is not temperature
dependent.
So what is it?
Well, if we look over here,
the natural log of A is going
to equal the natural log of k at
zero, over here,
and that means when one over T
is approximately zero.
At what kinds of temperatures
would one over T be
approximately zero?
Really, really big.
Factor A is the rate constant
for that reaction at some
infinitely huge temperature.
That is the maximum value that
you could get for that rate
constant.
At really, really huge
temperature that is what it is.
It is not temperature
dependent.
It is a quantity that is the
sort of maximum rate constant at
the biggest temperature that you
can think of.
That is what factor A is.
What about activation energy?
Is that going to be temperature
dependent?
No, it won't be temperature
dependent either.
You can calculate it.
It is the slope of the line.
So you can get it out of
plotting these values,
but it is going to depend on
the reaction being studied,
not the particular temperature.
And this is going to be
important in a few minutes
because we are going to be
talking about the effects of
rate constants on different
temperatures and looking at
equations and doing some
calculations.
Okay.
We can rewrite this equation in
a couple of different ways.
You will see that equation for
the straight line that Arrhenius
came up with.
It is often called the
Arrhenius equation.
And it can be written basically
just reversing these two terms,
I guess because it looks better
that way.
I am not really sure why you
cannot just keep it like that,
but you will see it this way.
And you will also see it
rewritten this way.
Instead of natural log of k,
you would see it as solved for
k.
Here, the rate constant is
equal to A, which is this factor
A.
This rate constant at infinity
huge temperatures times e to the
minus Ea, the activation energy,
over RT.
So you will also see this
equation this way.
It is a way of figuring out if
you know the activation energy
and you know factor A,
you can calculate rate
constants at a particular
temperature.
It is not only gases that
behave in this way,
that exhibit this Arrhenius
behavior.
And you can apply these
equations to other systems.
And let's just look at one
other example of something that
behaves with Arrhenius behavior.
What is that?
Crickets.
How many of you have heard
crickets in the wild?
Almost everybody.
I spent some years as a summer
camp counselor,
and we always had kids coming
to the country from the city.
And there would be crickets and
bull frogs.
And these poor kids that grew
up right outside a hospital
where all night long there would
be ambulances going by and
traffic and helicopters and all
sorts of things would sleep fine
at home, but then they would
come to the country and couldn't
sleep a wink because of all of
this noise.
The country is not as quiet as
people think it is.
Crickets will respond to
temperature, and so they
actually chirp faster when it is
hotter.
If you are out camping,
you can count how many chirps
there are in 14 seconds and add
that to 40 and get the
temperature in Fahrenheit.
Has anyone actually tried this?
Did it work?
You think so.
Did you have a control of a
thermometer with you?
No.
It probably works better if you
don't actually have the control,
but it should theoretically
work if you can do a good job
counting.
That is an example of a non-gas
exhibiting this behavior.
All right.
Let's talk more about the
activation energy.
We are going to talk a lot
about activation energy today.
Activation energy Ea.
If you have two molecules
coming together and colliding,
sometimes they will form
products, and sometimes they
will just fall away back into
reactants.
Not every collision will result
in product.
Why is that?
Only the collisions that have
the right amount of energy can
go on and form products.
Really, what activation energy
is, is some critical amount of
energy that is required to go on
and result in a reaction.
Only the molecules with that
critical energy,
when they come together,
they will go onto product.
Other molecules will come
together, and they will just
fall apart, because they won't
be able to overcome this
activation energy barrier.
Let's look at the affect of
temperature on the molecules
that have critical amounts of
energy.
If we plot, then,
fraction of molecules versus
kinetic energy.
And we can look at molecules
that have a low temperature,
or molecules at low
temperature.
There are some molecules at low
temperature, and we can look at
some fractions of molecules at
higher temperature,
and then consider the critical
energy needed to react.
The activation energy.
Molecules with that amount of
energy or more will be able to
react.
And, if you look at the
fraction of molecules,
then, that would have that
energy, at higher temperatures
more molecules have that
critical amount of energy.
And at lower temperature,
fewer molecules have that
critical amount of energy.
So temperature makes a
difference.
At higher temperature,
more things will be able to
react.
That is what gets into this
observation that reactions occur
faster at higher temperature.
More molecules have the
critical energy needed to react
when they are at higher
temperature.
At lower temperature it is more
difficult.
Fewer fractions of those
molecules have that critical
energy, can overcome an
activation energy barrier.
Let's look at an example,
now, of if you know what the
activation energy barrier is,
figuring out different rate
constants at different
temperatures,
how temperature is affecting
the rate of the reaction.
The example that we will look
at is the hydrolysis of sucrose.
And this is part of the
digestive process.
And digestion is a good thing.
Let's look at this particular
reaction.
We are given an activation
energy.
Someone has measured the
activation energy for the
hydrolysis of sucrose,
108 kilojoules per mole.
And someone has measured an
observed rate,
a k(obs) of 1.0x10^-3 per molar
per second at body temperature.
Now you are asked to figure out
what, would the observed rate
constant be if you lowered that
temperature, if you lowered it
by 2 degrees to 35 degrees?
You could right two different
expressions.
You can use Arrhenius equation
and write two different
expressions.
Over here we have the natural
log of k one,
the rate constant at one time,
and t one at that
temperature.
So, the rate constant at
temperature one.
That would be equal to the
natural log of factor A,
again, that is not temperature
dependent, minus Ea,
the activation energy,
and then it is over RT.
And we write the same
expression for a second
temperature and a second rate
constant.
Now we can combine these two
expressions and come up with one
equation.
If we subtract,
we have natural log of the rate
constant two minus the natural
log of rate constant one.
And that can also be expressed
in terms of natural log of k two
over k one.
And here we can pull out the
temperature terms.
Both of these have the same
expression, minus Ea over R,
the rate constant.
And now we have the two
temperatures.
This expression is telling us
how the rate constants are going
to change with temperature for a
particular activation energy.
What does this equation look
like?
It should look familiar to you.
Something that we talked about
before.
What was that equation called?
Van Hoff equation.
And instead of rate constants
we had what?
Instead of rate constants there
were?
Equilibrium constants.
And instead of Ea we had what?
What tells us about how
equilibrium constants change
with temperature?
If you have a reaction and you
heat up the reaction,
how do you know which direction
it shifts?
What is our predictive tool?
Delta H, right.
This equation is similar to one
we saw before.
Here we are comparing how rate
constants change with
temperature.
And a predictive tool is the
size, the magnitude of the
activation energy.
Before we were talking about
how rate constants change with
temperature.
And the predictive tool there
was delta H.
In case you need a review of
this, we will review this
actually at the end of the class
because this is very exciting.
At the end of the class we come
back to Le Châtelier's
principle.
And we can explain Le
Châletier's principle in terms
of temperature in a different
way than we did when we started
the course, because now we can
think about it in terms of
activation energies and rate
constants.
We will see that van Hoff
equation again.
For the moment now,
we are just considering how
rate constants are changing with
temperature.
We can plug in our values.
The initial observed rate for
the reaction at 37 degrees,
and we have k two that
we are going to solve for.
We were given the activation
energy.
And we know the gas constant,
and we were given the two
temperatures.
The only tricky thing here is
to remember to get your units to
cancel out.
Often activation energies are
given in kilojoules,
whereas your gas constant is in
joules.
The temperatures here were
given in Celsius,
but if you are using the gas
constant you are going to need
to convert them to Kelvin for
your units to cancel.
The only thing tricky about
this is to make sure that your
units are going to cancel.
And so we can solve this for k
two.
And k two comes out to be
7.6x10^-4 per molar per second.
It would be the same units as k
one, and that is quite a
bit slower.
We only changed our temperature
by 2 degrees,
and yet the rate is quite a bit
slower.
The body temperature is the
reactions, the enzymes in our
bodies, and how much they need
to work, how well they need to
work, is really optimized for
the temperature of our
particular body.
If your body temperature drops
quite a bit or if your body
temperature goes up quite a bit,
that is not good for the
overall working of the human
body.
Just some advice for a day like
today.
It is best to keep your body
temperature at normal body
temperature if you are spending
a lot of time outside.
Wear a hat, wear a scarf,
wear gloves,
wear real shoes,
not sort of flip-flop type
things, and you should be able
to continue your hydrolyze your
sucrose and digest.
You have to start worrying
about what clothes you are
wearing this time of year in
Boston, for those of you who are
from warmer climates.
All right.
If we look at this equation
again, we will see that if this
term is large,
if you have a large activation
energy, if you have a large
critical energy needed for that
reaction to go,
then that reaction will be very
sensitive to changes in
temperature, i.e.,
if this is a big number,
then you are going to see a big
difference between k one
and k two.
This will tell you a lot about
the reaction.
And we will come back to this
idea in a little bit.
All right.
Let's consider the reaction
coordinate and activated
complexes.
There is this critical
collision energy,
this activation energy that is
needed for these molecules to
actually react.
Why does this happen?
Well, as two molecules may come
toward each other,
they may not be able to react
if they don't have that energy.
Well, why do they need energy?
Well, they may need to sort of
rearrange.
A bond may be broken.
An atom may fall to the ground.
New reactions are occurring.
There is energy needed to get
your desired product.
They have to distort.
The bonds need to distort,
and that requires energy.
The result is that usually,
before you go on to your
products, so say this is one of
your products,
you need to usually form some
kind of intermediate state,
some kind of activated complex
or transition state.
And that transition state can
either go on to products or fall
back to reactants.
And only those molecules with
this energy can do this
reaction, can overcome this
barrier and go on to form
products.
And I will show you a little
movie of two molecules coming
together.
They are going to circle each
other and figure out if they
have the critical energy to
react, and when they have that
critical energy you will know
it, and go onto product.
Let's just take a look at this
reaction.
Here comes a molecule in red
and in blue.
They are checking each other
out.
They had enough energy and they
went on and formed product.
But only those molecules with
that energy can go and form the
product.
All right.
Let's draw a reaction
coordinate now and look at these
activation energy barriers and
these transition complexes.
All right.
A reaction coordinate diagram
has potential energy on one
side, --
-- and has the reaction
coordinate on the other axis.
And that just means the
direction of the reaction.
A reaction will start with
reactants with a particular
energy.
In this case,
we are going to look at NO two
plus CO.
We have two reactants at a
particular energy.
And then these will react.
They will need to form some
kind of activated complex up
here.
Say, there are bonds distorting
and new bonds forming.
There is some kind of
intermediate state,
some kind of activated complex
or transition state.
There will be energy associated
with getting up here.
If they have the critical
energy to react,
they will go on,
then, to products.
And our products here are NO
plus CO two.
And these are our products.
And so that is what the
reaction coordinate will look
like.
If they didn't have enough
energy, it would just come back
down here.
This barrier up here is the
activation energy for the
forward reaction,
and this over here is the
activation energy for the
reverse reaction.
And, overall,
you have a delta E for the
system.
So, the difference between the
energy of the reactants and the
products.
Delta E is going to equal the
activation energy for the
forward reaction minus the
reverse reaction.
And we can put some numbers on
this.
For the forward reaction it is
132 kilojoules per mole,
for the reverse reaction we
have 358 kilojoules per mole,
and our overall delta E value
is going to be minus 226
kilojoules per mole.
Minus 226 kilojoules per mole
is going to be equal to the 132
kilojoules per mole minus the
358 kilojoules per mole.
These are all going to add up.
And that is one of the
equations on your equation sheet
that you need to know for the
final that won't be provided.
But it makes rational sense
that these should all add up
together.
All right.
How does this relate?
Delta E, what is this delta E?
Well, this is a quantity that
can be measured.
It is a thermodynamic quantity.
It can come from calorimetry
experiments.
And it is related to a friend
of ours, delta H.
If you recall,
delta H equals delta E plus the
change in PV.
And I think this was Lecture 17
from Professor Ceyer's notes
when she started talking about
thermodynamics.
And so most of the time,
these are pretty similar to
each other.
For gases, there is a little
bit of a difference.
This term exists.
You might have like a 1% to 2%
difference, but is more or less
the same.
If it helps you to think about
this as more or less the same as
the delta H, that can be useful
for you.
They are very similar
quantities there.
Okay.
Again, there is a barrier.
And for this reaction,
there is a smaller barrier
going in the forward direction,
the smaller activation energy,
and a much bigger barrier for
the reverse direction of this
reaction.
If we think about activation
energy barriers,
every reaction is going to have
some activation energy barrier,
just like most things we do in
life have some activation energy
barrier.
For me, writing papers or
writing grants,
there is a very large
activation energy barrier to get
started.
The getting started part,
and it is usually kind of more
like this direction.
This kind of size activation
energy barrier.
Once I manage to kind of get up
over the hump,
really get started,
then it becomes much easier,
and I can really get going with
this.
I imagine that if I recall back
to studying for final exams,
going back over the old
material that you already
covered and reviewing that,
there is a sizable activation
energy barrier to pulling out
those first set of notes and
pulling out Exam 1.
And looking at the things you
got wrong and going back over it
has an activation energy
barrier.
And what we are going to talk
about on Monday a little bit are
some tricks to get over those
activation energy barriers.
Catalysts can lower the
activation energy barrier.
And, for most of us,
an enormous level of stress can
also help us get over that
activation energy barrier.
Your professor,
for example,
mentioning the final exam every
day before class starts can be a
little help getting over that
activation energy barrier to
start reviewing material.
This kind of plot,
you should feel like you should
bond with this idea of
activation energy barriers.
You should understand the
deepest level about these
barriers that these molecules
need to overcome.
All right.
Let's look at the affect of
temperature on whether molecules
can make it over those
activation energy barriers.
Again, for an elementary
reaction there is always a
barrier.
Sometimes it is smaller,
sometimes it is larger,
but there is always a barrier
to that.
There is always a positive Ea
here.
Okay.
What happens if you increase
temperature?
If you increase temperature,
it should increase the rate,
because of this down here.
You increase temperature,
more molecules will have the
energy required to make it over
that barrier.
For an elementary reaction,
increasing temperature will
increase the rate.
It will get over the barrier.
For an overall reaction,
for a more complicated reaction
that has multiple steps,
it is not necessarily clear
that temperature is going to
have this affect.
And let's consider why this is
true.
Let's look at the same reaction
we looked at with mechanisms
last time and figure out what
all the k observed
terms are.
Are there small rate constants?
Are there equilibrium
constants?
What does k(obs) really mean?
And then we can think about how
temperature would affect those
values.
Here we have a reaction with
the fast reversible step
followed by another step that is
slow.
We can say that the rate of
product formation,
our product here is NO two,
is going to be equal to
two, because two were formed,
k two,
this rate constant,
times this intermediate here
times the concentration of
oxygen.
That is just this last step.
This slow step rate of
formation of product.
But this is an intermediate,
so we are not done.
We have to get rid of this
intermediate.
And here, we can do it fairly
efficiently, because we have a
fast reversible step followed by
a slow step.
We can approximate that this
step is in equilibrium.
And, if we approximate that,
then we can solve for this
intermediate in terms of an
equilibrium expression.
Again, the first step fast and
reversible, the second step
slow.
This is pretty much in
equilibrium.
Not much of this intermediate
is being siphoned off to
products.
We can solve by setting up an
equilibrium expression.
Here is the equilibrium
expression.
Equilibrium constant for Step 1
equals rate constant for the
forward reaction over rate
constant for the reverse
reaction equals products over
reactants.
There are two reactants,
two NO, so it is NO squared.
And we can solve for the
concentration of the
intermediate,
then, which would be k one
times NO squared.
Now we can substitute that in
the overall expression,
and we have this expression
here.
Now our k(obs) is going to be
equal to this two k two
and big K one.
This is what we need to
consider, how that is affected
by temperature.
Little k two is an
elementary rate constant.
For an elementary reaction,
increasing temperature will
always increase rate.
We know how this affected.
And here is our expression that
we looked at before.
Now, what about the equilibrium
constant?
How do you know what is going
to happen with an equilibrium
constant, if it will get bigger
or smaller with temperature?
What is the equation that
relates equilibrium constants
and temperature?
Van Hoff, right.
It depends on delta H.
It depends on whether the
reaction is endothermic or
exothermic.
And here is that expression.
You can see these are really
very similar expressions.
Here we have the equilibrium
constants.
Delta H is our predictive tool.
Whether that is endothermic or
exothermic will depend on what
direction it goes.
It will depend on whether K one
is bigger than k two or k two is
bigger than k one with change in
temperature.
And over here we have the
expression that relates rate
constants with temperature.
And, in terms of sign,
that is not an issue here,
because activation energy is
always positive.
There is always a barrier to
overcome.
That is always positive.
Never a negative barrier.
There is no sign change here,
but there is an effective
magnitude of that value as there
is with this.
So it is not so simple.
If you have a multistep
reaction, it is not always so
simple to predict the affect of
temperature, because it may be
changing one thing in one way
and something else in another
way.
Let's consider this particular
one here.
Again, little k is always going
to increase with temperature.
The equilibrium constant,
in this case,
will decrease,
because it is an exothermic
reaction.
This particular reaction is
exothermic.
If we think about Le Châtelier
or we think about the van Hoff
equation, we say if it an
exothermic reaction,
increasing the temperature will
decrease the K,
because you are going to shift
the reaction in the endothermic
reaction to use up the heat.
The magnitude of the increase
or decrease will depend on the
magnitude of the energy barrier
and the magnitude of delta H.
If we look at this particular
example and you are told that
the activation energy is a small
number, it is not a very big
activation energy barrier.
And you are also told then that
delta H is a big number,
and it is a big negative
number, what would that mean,
then?
Well, if you look at this,
if you have a small number for
activation energy,
then there is not going to be a
big difference between the Ks.
The rate constant is only going
to increase a little bit,
because this is a small number.
On the other hand,
if delta H is a big number,
and you are told delta H is a
big number, then the equilibrium
constant should be very
sensitive to changes in
temperature.
You should see a big difference
in the equilibrium constants,
because this is a really big
number.
This particular reaction is an
example where increasing the
temperature can actually
decrease the observed rate.
And the effect is because of
the delta H.
Again, a large activation
energy means that the rate
constant is very sensitive to
changes in temperature,
a large delta H means that the
equilibrium constant is very
sensitive to changes in
temperature.
Our predictors are activation
energy and also delta H,
in thinking about what might
happen when the temperature of a
reaction changes.
And we mentioned that this is
always going to increase,
rate constant will always
increase with temperature.
And you can easily remember
this, that there is always a
barrier.
You don't get a great deal.
There is always a barrier to
overcome.
And delta H can be positive or
negative, so equilibrium
constants can increase or
decrease with temperature.
For delta H,
magnitude of delta H indicates
the magnitude of the change.
Sign of delta H indicates the
direction of the change.
And, if you forget that,
you can just look at the
equations and they will tell you
the same thing.
Now we can come back to Le
Châtelier.
We can explain those
observations about how
equilibrium constants changed.
And how the reaction was
affected, why you would shift in
one direction versus another
when you change the temperature.
Again, Le Châtelier says that a
system that is at equilibrium,
if you have the system at
equilibrium and you apply a
stress, the system will respond
in such a way to minimize that
stress.
If you increased the
temperature, the equilibrium
should shift in the endothermic
direction.
That would be what the
prediction would be from Le
Châtelier, because if you put in
more heat the reaction wants to
respond in a way to decrease the
heat.
And so it goes in the direction
that absorbs heat,
the endothermic direction.
This is what we talked about
before, but now we can think
about this in a little bit of a
different way in terms of these
reaction coordinate diagrams.
Let's look at an endothermic
versus exothermic reaction.
Here we have an endothermic
reaction.
We have reactants here,
we have a large activation
energy in the forward direction,
we have products up here,
and a smaller activation energy
in the reverse direction.
For this exothermic reaction,
we have a smaller activation
energy in the forward direction.
And a much larger one in the
reverse direction.
Our equation here would then
indicate you have an endothermic
reaction, your delta E is
positive, if you have a big
number for the forward minus a
small number for the reverse.
That is going to give you a
positive overall number.
Whereas, in this case,
if you have a small number here
minus a much bigger number,
you get a negative number for
delta E or an exothermic
reaction.
If you are given information
about the activation energy in
the forward direction and in the
reverse direction and ask if a
reaction is endothermic or
exothermic, you can figure that
out using this equation.
Now let's think about
temperature.
If there is a small barrier,
only a small barrier,
most of your molecules can
probably get over that small
barrier.
It's not that hard.
But if there is a very large
barrier, that is a problem.
Temperature helps with the big
barriers.
The small barrier,
the molecules are going over
anyway.
The bigger barriers,
they need extra help.
They need the help of increased
temperature.
If we consider what happens,
increasing temperature here,
the big barrier is the forward
direction.
Increasing the temperature will
make it easier to overcome this
very large barrier.
It makes very little difference
here.
The molecules are already doing
fine getting over the small
barrier, but here,
there is a big help.
What this does,
then, is it shifts the
equilibrium toward products.
Increasing temperature for an
endothermic reaction shifts
toward products.
That is what we learned before,
but we had a different
rationale for it last time.
Now let's consider this case.
If you increase temperature,
it is going to affect the
reverse barrier more.
That is the big barrier.
This is where molecules are
having a difficult time.
They are getting over that
barrier already,
so in this case,
when you have this exothermic
reaction, adding temperature is
going to shift toward reactants.
It will shift it in the
endothermic direction using up
the heat.
Again, this is what we saw
before.
But now we have a different
explanation for why.
Again, a large activation
energy barrier means that the
rate constants are very
sensitive to temperature.
It is highly affected.
If it is big,
it is large.
It needs temperature for the
molecules to get over.
Increasing the temperature has
a big effect.
Now molecules can do it.
They can get over.
This is why a large barrier
means that a reaction is
sensitive to temperature.
Big activation energy,
big difference.
Small activation energy,
not such a big difference.